[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen ins all
israels valentinstag steht wieder vor
der tür und in den letzten jahren habe
ich bereits einige ideen und rezepte den
für euch hochgeladen
da dürfte gern mal in meiner
valentinstags playlist vorbeischauen
heute gibt es ein herz auf das gericht
nämlich valentinstags kartoffel rosen
valentinstag des weit mehr am 14 februar
und das geht auf den heiligen valentinus
zurück ich muss sagen bei uns
wir vergessen zimmer also so auf social
media in meinen rezepten teile ich das
natürlich immer ganz gerne aber so wenn
dann valentinstag ist dann vergessen was
meistens oder einen von uns fällt ein
mein gott ihr könnt ja mal schreiben ob
ihr valentinstag gefeiert oder nicht
jedenfalls habe ich trotzdem ein sehr
schönes rezept für euch und dieses
rezept könnt ihr natürlich nicht nur zu
valentinstag zubereiten sondern jeden
tag weil man seine tat natürlich jeden
tag dient und nicht nur einmal im jahr
ach das war doch ist schön ihr könnt das
rezept so zubereiten wie ich es machen
oder ihr könnt auch vegan zu bereiten
also ich benutze gleich passte denn
hinterschinken ihr könnt es aber auch
weglassen und das ganze wirklich vegan
oder auch vegetarisch zu bereiten ich
habe ich jetzt schon meine kartoffeln
geschält das gewicht brauche ich etwa
300 gramm dann nämlich olivenöl und ich
habe jetzt hier einmal mein knoblauch
olivenöl und das rosmarin olivenöl dann
die gewürze salz und pfeffer etwas
thymian rinder schinken dann nämlich
jetzt passt seine und blätterteig und
entweder nimmt ihr jetzt einen
rosmarinzweig und eine knoblauchzehe und
könnte es mit dazu geben oder wie gesagt
verwendet die einfach knoblauch und
rosmarin ja jetzt erst mal die
kartoffeln schälen und
am besten keine zu kleinen kartoffeln
damit das ganze ein bisschen einfacher
geht
[Musik]
und dann kurz die kartoffeln abwaschen
damit der schmutz hier beseitigt wird
[Musik]
und jetzt können wir die kartoffeln ganz
fein hobeln entweder nehmen wir den
sparschäler dazu der küchenmöbel oder in
der küchenmaschine ich mache das jetzt
zählen der küchenmaschine das geht
einfach schöne dünne scheiben damit die
schön flexibel sind zum aufrollen für
die rose
ich habe zu ihr auf der kenwood da zwei
scheiben für hobel einmal dick aber dann
zeige ich mal kurz
und das hier ist diese dünne scheibe die
scheibe 4
[Musik]
das geht ziemlich schnell
es kommt hier alles in eine große
schüssel
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch auch noch
an meine apfel rosen die man auch ich
lebe mit äpfeln sauer rahmen sauerkraut
röstzwiebeln auch richtig lecker auch
herzhaft tatsächlich jetzt gebt ihr da
das olivenöl dazu einmal knoblauch
einmal rosmarin
die gewürze rein salz pfeffer und ein
bisschen thymian
das riecht jetzt verbot
jetzt schön durchmischen
[Musik]
jetzt wird aufgeräumt
ich nehme jetzt hier mein pass firma
denn rinder schenken da hat er oben
diese gewürz passte und die ist echt
extrem lecker bringt da nochmal
zusätzlichen geschmack mit rein das
ganze ist aber ein bisschen zu breit
deswegen lege ich die kurz übereinander
schneider immer durch in dünne streifen
den blätterteig schneide jetzt in zwölf
streifen
und dann geht's jetzt los am besten
nimmt jetzt passt immer die gewürz
passte nach unten weil die ganz gerne
mal im ofen verbrennt und wie gesagt
wenn ihr jetzt das ganze vegetarisch
oder vegan zubereitet könnte jetzt in
blätterteig zum beispiel mit tomatenmark
bestreichen oder auch ein veganes
ersatzprodukt verwenden ich finde es
sollte einfach nur farblich sind bisher
den kontrast mit rein
dann nehme ich mir die kartoffeln die
sind jetzt noch ein bisschen zu groß das
heißt ihr nehmt euch hier
legt sie übereinander und halb jetzt
einmal dass ich eine gerade fläche in
der mitte habe dann habe ich ihn machen
blech da kommt ein bisschen olivenöl mit
rein damit nix anklebt
könnt ihr auch gerne rosmarin oder
knoblauch olivenöl verwenden und wer es
scharf mag chili
ich habe mich nicht in weitere wortwitze
zu machen
natürlich mal was schaaf am valentinstag
schadet da ist
unterwegs
dann haben wir das vergnügen
das rezept zu verkosten und jetzt schön
aufwickeln das heißt ihr nehmt euch
jetzt diese kartoffeln packt sie da rein
so ein bisschen überlappend und dann
sieht es später aus wie eine
wunderschöne rose
hier von der seite her aufwickeln
hat überlegt so man könnte ja auch
seinen sohn nach dem backen sondern
ringen in der mitte falls jemand und
valentinstag einen heiratsantrag machen
will habe ich glaube es gibt romantische
riss zwischen kacheln und pasta
[Gelächter]
manchmal geht die romantikerin in mir
durch ich sag's euch
ihr könnt das gericht auch gerne mit
eurem partner zu bereiten ganz easy
[Musik]
wenn ihr dann diese rose habt dann könnt
ihr sie so leicht öffnen die blüten nach
außen und ab damit ähnlich machen kaum
[Musik]
sie sehen richtig hübsch aus so kommen
sie jetzt in den vorgeheizten backofen
bei 170 grad heißluft und dürfen etwa 30
35 minuten backen
wenn ihr noch kartoffeln übrig habt ich
habe auch noch ein paar kleine teilchen
dann packt sie einfach in den ofen form
und ganz einfach auch da muss man nichts
verschwenden nichts wegschmeißen und
dann bin ich schon gespannt darauf wie
sie gleich schmecken werden
[Musik]
für die vegane version verwendet die
einfach etwas tomatenmark mischt das mit
etwas chili olivenöl zum beispiel am
salz und pfeffer dazu schneidet dann
eure platte wieder in streifen und
bestreicht die komplette platte mit
tomatenmark und dann kommen da wieder
die fächer kartoffeln drauf das ganze
wird aufgerollt und im ofen gebacken und
die version ist deswegen vegan weil der
blätterteig mittlerweile einfach nicht
mal mit butter zubereitet wird deswegen
ist es nicht nur vegetarisch sondern
rein pflanzlich weg
[Musik]
jetzt sind die rosen fertig finde es ja
auch richtig richtig schön murat ist
heute leider nicht da aber dass er ganz
typisch weil valentinstag ist vermutet
immer nicht ganz so wichtig also habe
ich mir gedacht wer kann dem moratorium
das kann nur einer hier und es ist der
thomas thomas
[Gelächter]
ich hab ich schon mal als beim
jahresrückblick ebenso eine peinliche
missliche lage gebracht und noch nichts
dazu sagen okay wir haben da so
thomas ist einfach immer gut trauer von
immer neue aus- und dadurch uns so eine
bindung sich ja was hat valentinstag für
dich für eine bedeutung du musst jetzt
nichts sagen du darfst aber also für
mich ist es das typische das rose herr
babbel ist das vielleicht sagen gibt es
jemanden mit dem sie den valentinstag
verkündet es gibt
zwar ist es mich auch
okay du musst nicht mehr sagen aber da
darf jeder sei ich glaube wäre schon
ganz viele valentinstag gemeinsam
verbracht hat das sind meine eltern
diesen nämlich auch gerade gekommen ich
glaube die holen jetzt auch mal dazu
hat 48 jahre verheiratet was kannst du
das vorstelle 78 jahre mit ein und
derselben person das ist dann die
goldene hochzeit weil 50 er ja selber
war schon jetzt kommt jetzt kommt die
goldene hochzeit
eine schöne darauf was
für mein papa ist jeden tag valentinstag
lösung oder anders gesagt er will nichts
kaufen
ok-chef hier kartoffel rosen mit pasta
und vegetarisch
was wollt ihr problem kontoauszug
probieren die sind gut mit rinder
schinke und die sind vegetarisch ohne
basta
sagt pastor schuhsohle
[Musik]
stimmt eigentlich total wird mit dem
basteln und stinkt danach komplett nach
bockshornklee und claude laut
nachgedacht das wäre so ein fall für die
nicolet gewesen weil die nicolet hätte
mir jetzt gesagt zum valentinstag
essen kein knoblauch keine zwiebeln nix
was aufbläht
keine bohnen
keine linsen und vielleicht kein passt
aber gut man kann ja auch mein gott wenn
es beide ersten stinken weiter den
rhythmus nicht wo wir sagen wir uns alle
aber
eine hübsche idee
oder ist ich hab die quasi aus
blätterteig und dann so
aufgeregt
ja also probiert gerne aus ihr könnt ja
immer schreiben ob ihr die stink version
oder sie nicht stinkt versiert im wald
finde ich sehr lecker und
dazu kann man ja an salat reichen oder
einen leckeren fit machen wobei ich
finde da braucht man eigentlich nichts
salat war ganz gut dann ist es so ein
komplettes menü viel spaß beim
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
und schaut euch gerne die valentinstags
ideen vom letzten jahr noch an
jetzt gehen wir mal gucken morath ist
eine tat und suche ich mir andere
valentin
[Musik]